you may remember last week we covered a
little bit of video from this
disinformation
gathering this was the video that i
showed you where
a young student from the university of
chicago
he basically just nailed brian stelter
he asked him about the misinformation
that they share on cnn and stelter
basically was like well let's go to
lunch
um well there's more video leaking out
from this conference and they had amy
klobuchar there you may remember amy
klobuchar she ran for president got
about one percent of the vote then
dropped out back biden that's what you
got to do
and now she's involved in misinformation
as it relates to big tech and science
scary pandemics and all of those things
and listen to the question here related
to health misinformation and listen to
her answer you introduced the bill that
you talked about today
that would punish social media companies
like facebook and twitter for
having health misinformation on their
platforms
and i'm gonna ask you if i were to say
that there are only two sexes
male and female
would that be considered misinformation
that you think should be banned uh
speech on social media
platforms i'm not going to get into what
misinformation first of all i think the
bill you're talking about is different
than the one we've mostly been talking
about so i want to make that clear we've
been talking about the competition bill
um but there is another bill that i have
on vaccine misinformation it is that
specific in a public health crisis you
wonder why you get that specific
it's because we're trying to find carve
outs that i did with this was with ben
ray lujan
that got to
that you can't have immunity as a social
media company if you are
broadcasting
vaccine
misinformation
truth coming this way
off-ramp yeah of course you can't answer
the question the basic purpose of the
question are there biological
differences between men and women the
democrat party at this point has no one
as far as i know in the party that can
say that men and women
are different
i'm not a biologist but it's something
like this
men have penises women have vaginas
this is this is the most incredible show
we've ever done i really feel that i'm
pushing the limits of what thank you got
a thumbs up over there uh they cannot
stop themselves these people because
they lo everything that they do every
policy that they bring in everything
that they want this country to be is
based on their power hungry destruction
of
reality that's what it is so she can't
answer whether if you say that a man is
a man and a woman is a woman and these
are two distinct different things
whether you'll be banned from social
media whether she would be for that and
then she basically gives this sort of
broad nothingness answer related to
misinformation when it comes to
covid in essence is what they're talking
about because they're talking about
science misinformation and what should
happen to these big tech companies and
yet we know
that if you were going to be banning
people
for covet misinformation you'd have to
ban joe biden who said if you take the
vaccine you will not get or transmit
covet you'd have to ban everybody that's
involved with these this clown car of
stupidity